the hit podcast a slight change of plans
looks at how life-changing events affect
who we are it Blends storytelling with
the science of human behavior it has
featured candid conversation with big
names like Hillary Clinton author Adam
Grant Amanda Knox and Theron knows
whistleblower Erica Chung Apple named
the podcast best show of the year in
2021. it's been downloaded more than 8
million yep that's right 8 million times
since its launch so Maya the premiere of
its fifth season is this week cognitive
scientist Maya shunker is the host and
creator of the podcast good morning how
are you doing good morning
good afternoon so one human behavior you
delve into is people's fear of change
yes tell us a little bit more about that
yes so we have an allergy as humans
towards uncertainty
um so there's a study showing that
people who were told they had a 50
chance of getting an electric shock were
significantly more stressed out than
those who were told they had a 50 chance
100 chance of getting an electric shock
and so really we would rather be certain
that a terrible thing is going to happen
than to have to deal or manage with any
feelings of ambiguity or uncertainty
that makes sense why because you know
it's coming if somebody says a hundred
percent but but Nate and Maya we are the
most adaptable and I don't like whole
plants we are the most adaptable animals
on the whole planet so we're good at
change actually so why are we so afraid
of it no it's a great point we are
really good at change in some ways but
then also change can threaten our sense
of identity sometimes and that can be
very destabilizing
um so one woman I talked to on the show
her name is Christy Warren she is a
listener of a slight change of plans and
she was telling me about her career as a
paramedic and a firefighter and after
Decades of serving others she realized
that she had to actually save herself
because she was diagnosed with
debilitating PTSD and in that moment she
had to try to figure out how do I
redefine myself now that I can no longer
wear this hero cape and help others
every single day do I still have value
in this world and so our conversation is
about that one of my favorite you kick
off the season with Ruby Bridges I so
love Ruby Bridges and talk about slight
change of plans she's a little black
girl six years old who integrates in
Louisiana for the first time in school
but when she goes she doesn't even know
what is happening to her yeah you know
she's just told you're going to a new
school so she's very excited about that
and these white men two Marshals come
and say we're going to escort you to
school she goes okay that's kind of cool
but she doesn't really realize what is
happening because she was not told yes
Gail I was surprised founded to have
this conversation with her because like
so many people watching this I read
about the bridges in my history books
right but it wasn't until our
conversation on a slight change of plans
that I fully internalized what this
experience was like through the lens of
a six-year-old yeah and as you mentioned
as it turns out no one told Ruby what
was happening or why she was not told
that there were desegregation efforts
happening across her City she was not
told why Federal Marshals showed up at
her doorstep to escort her to school for
her safety can you imagine that no I
can't 60 years old she felt very special
and it was only when she was 17 that a
reporter asked her that she realized oh
that that was such a that was a
groundbreaking game-changing event
Daniel pink talking about regret yes how
we should all use regret as a Force for
good that we don't come to terms with
regret I thought this was an interesting
conversation too yeah so regret is one
of those icky stomach turning negative
feelings that we all try to run away
from
possible I certainly do but Dan teaches
us that if we can meaningfully engage
with our regrets and he teaches us how
exactly to do that there's good ways and
bad ways to engage with regret it can
actually lead us to live more productive
happy lives and I actually saw this I
love it when the science is corroborated
by the stories of the guests yeah and so
I talked with Jason Isbell who is a
singer-songwriter and Jason regretted so
much of his past when he was an
alcoholic and when he became sober he
did what so many of us might do in that
situation which is we try to villainize
his past self as a way of avoiding a
relapse he tried to create as much
psychological space between present-day
Jason and past Jason a lot of people do
that absolutely and what he learned over
time was that he could actually learn
from his regress that he could Embrace
old Jason in this compassionate way
while still staying sober it's okay to
create a bridge with who you used to be
yeah exactly well said uh the only
certainty is uncertainty right yeah
humans make plans God laughs so what can
people do in their everyday life to
manage what is going to be a different
kind of day good question Tony I got my
pen and paper ready great question Tony
um okay I'll give you two quick tips
okay the first is that we can invite all
inspiring experiences into our lives
this can be as simple as noticing a
beautiful sunset or looking at a flower
I'm not talking about going to the Grand
Junction 10 seconds and then the second
thing we can do is invite daily reliable
rituals into our lives like a hot cup of
tea in the morning CBS Morning watching
TV this morning
you can listen to slight change of plans
wherever you like your podcast